Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. This is the second part in a two-part special on the Watergate scandal. In the first part, top historian of modern America, Dominic Sandbrook, futilely attempted to deal with the whole topic in a single episode. We went through the life of and career of Richard Nixon and then we started on the countdown to the the break into the Watergate complex to
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》。这是水门事件两集特别节目的第二部分。在第一部分中，当代美国顶尖历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）徒劳地试图在短短一集里讲完这个宏大的话题。我们回顾了理查德·尼克松的生平与政治生涯，然后开始倒计时，聚焦于
bug the democratic is it party convention it's a democratic national committee party yeah so they're basically democratic party headquarters yeah okay and so they they've been the people doing that have been caught red-handed nixon has said we've got to try and cover it up this will be the smoking gun and now dominic we can get back to the action and the countdown to what will be ultimately nixon's resignation but i'd like to to kick off with a question from stephen wills who asks when did nixon know the game was up and was there any chance he could have stayed so that's the kind of the context for what over the next what is it year and a half nixon's attempt to stop this from destroying his presence well first of all um i never really
潜入水门大厦，在民主党——是民主党全国代表大会吗？对，是民主党全国委员会——窃听。所以他们实际上是民主党总部，对吧？好的。因此，做这件事的人被当场抓获，尼克松说我们必须设法掩盖，这将是确凿的铁证。现在，多米尼克，我们可以回到正题，进入尼克松最终辞职的倒计时。不过我想以斯蒂芬·威尔斯（Stephen Wills）的一个问题开场，他问：尼克松是什么时候知道大势已去的？他还有没有可能留任？这就是未来大约一年半时间里的背景——尼克松试图阻止这件事毁掉他的总统任期。首先，嗯，我从来没
intended to do it in an hour i was lying when i i always thought it would take two episodes i mean if we could do two episodes on Thermopylae and Salamis without even mentioning Thermopylae and Salamis in the first episode, we could definitely do two episodes on Watergate. Now, when did Nixon know the game was up? He's not going to know the game is up for two more years. I mean, in the first episode, somebody asked, you know, why is Watergate so resonant?
打算在一小时内讲完。我之前说一小时是撒谎的，我一直认为这需要两集。我的意思是，如果我们能用两集来讲温泉关之役和萨拉米斯之役，甚至在第一集里连温泉关和萨拉米斯之役都没提到，那我们绝对可以用两集来讲水门事件。那么，尼克松是什么时候知道大势已去的呢？两年多里他都不会知道大势已去。我的意思是，在第一集里，有人问，你知道的，为什么水门事件会有这么大的共鸣？
Why is everything... I mean, it's partly because it goes on so long. So, June 17th of June 1972, You know, why is Watergate so resonant? Why is everything? I mean, it's partly because it goes on so long. So, 17th of June, 1972, is when the second burglary happens that is detected and the burglars are caught. So we talked about that last time. The 23rd of June, 1972, is when Nixon says to his chief of staff on tape,
为什么一切……我的意思是，部分原因是因为它持续了太久。所以，1972年6月17日，你知道的，为什么水门事件会有这么大的共鸣？为什么一切……我的意思是，部分原因是因为它持续了太久。所以，1972年6月17日，是第二次江洋大盗行窃被发现、窃贼被抓获的日子。我们上次已经讨论过了。1972年6月23日，尼克松在录音带中对他的幕僚长说，
we have to basically abuse our powers, get the CIA to stop stop get the fbi to stop the investigation stop it going higher up and then what happens really interestingly is kind of nothing for six months or more so the in which time he wins he romps home in the election and as i said last time he celebrates by sitting on his own, listening to music in his sepulchral gloom and writing on a pad about all the nasty things that people will say about him. So he's very bitter.
我们基本上必须滥用权力，让中情局停止——让联邦调查局停止调查，阻止它往更高层蔓延。然后，非常有趣的事情发生了，接下来的六个月或更长时间里，几乎什么都没发生。在这期间，他在大选中大获全胜。正如我上次所说，他独自坐在阴暗的墓穴般 gloom 中，听着音乐，在记事本上写下人们会怎样说他的种种坏话，以此来庆祝胜利。所以他内心非常痛苦。
He's actually really bitter after he's won this election. You described him as a Shakespearean figure. And I suppose that sense of you know absolute crushing success victory affirmation while at the same time you've got this scandal which is like a kind of little hint of dry rot absolutely in the wall that's that's exactly slowly spread and spread and spread and nothing he can do that's exactly right one of his aides later on john dean who will come to um describes that he says to nixon at one point there's a cancer on the presidency and it's growing and it's actually not a bad image it's something's very small almost imperceptible at
赢得这场大选后，他实际上感到非常痛苦。你把他描述为一个莎士比亚式的人物。我想那种……你知道的，绝对压倒性的成功、胜利、肯定，与此同时你又遭遇了这个丑闻，它就像墙里的一点点干腐病，绝对的，慢慢地蔓延、蔓延、蔓延，而他无能为力。完全正确。他后来的一个助手约翰·迪恩（John Dean）——我们稍后会提到——描述过这一点，他曾在某个时刻对尼克松说，总统身上长了癌症，而且它还在扩散。这其实是个不错的比喻：一开始它非常微小，几乎察觉不到，
first a nothing story but as you say it's going to grow and grow and grow and consume him so november 1972 he wins this crushing landslide. January 1973, he is inaugurated for the second term. And they get peace in Vietnam, which they've been waiting for all this time. So it looks OK. And all this time, they have been paying off the burglars, by the way. They have given them, I think, something like $430,000. Have the burglars not been arrested? Yeah, they've been arrested, but they need to be told...
只是一个小新闻，但正如你所说，它不断扩散、扩大，最终吞噬了他。所以，1972年11月，他以压倒性优势大获全胜。1973年1月，他宣誓就职第二个任期。他们迎来了期待已久的越南和平。所以看起来一切都还不错。顺便说一句，在这期间，他们一直在向窃贼支付封口费。我想他们大概已经付了大约43万美元。窃贼没有被捕吗？对，他们被捕了，但需要有人告诉他们……
Someone's got to pay their legal fees. These are not rich men. So someone has... Right, and also, are they being paid to keep quiet about it? They're being basically paid to keep quiet. They're described as loss of earnings, because loss of earnings through being in prison. Yes, exactly right.
总得有人支付他们的法律费用。这些人可不是富豪。所以总得有人……没错，而且，付钱是为了让他们保持沉默吗？基本上就是付钱让他们保持沉默。这被称为“收入损失”，因为入狱而导致的收入损失。是的，完全正确。
But in January 1973, so at the same time that Nixon's having these tremendous triumphs, they are convicted, obviously, because they're caught red-handed, and they're going to be sentenced in March 1973. So the question for Nixon is, if they keep quiet, and if nobody really digs into this he can probably get away with it but all it takes is one of them to break or it takes is somebody to start really following the money and so on and he'll be in trouble now the washington post the woodwood
但在1973年1月，也就是尼克松春风得意之时，他们显然被定罪了，因为他们被当场抓获，并将于1973年3月被判刑。所以尼克松面临的问题是，如果他们保持沉默，如果没人真正深究此事，他可能就能蒙混过关。但只要其中一个人崩溃，或者有人开始顺藤摸瓜，他就会陷入麻烦。现在，《华盛顿邮报》的伍德沃德——
carl woodward no carl bernstein rather and bob woodward uh have been writing about following the money trail. They have an informant in the FBI called Deep Throat, who turns out to be the... OK, I think we've got a question. Oh, very good. Can somebody ask who came up with the name Deep Throat? I don't actually know who came up with it.
卡尔·伍德沃德，不，卡尔·伯恩斯坦和鲍勃·伍德沃德一直在撰写关于顺藤摸瓜追踪资金流向的文章。他们在联邦调查局有一个线人叫“深喉”，后来证明他就是……好吧，我想我们有一个问题。哦，很好。有人能问问是谁想出了“深喉”这个名字吗？其实我不知道是谁想出来的。
I did know, but I've forgotten. So Deep Throat is a porn film from the early 1970s. And the guy is Mark Felt. He's the deputy FBI director. He's not a friend of the White House. The funny thing is, actually, there's this huge sort of hullabaloo when it turned out to be him. But actually, the Nixon White House had always known he was leaking to the press. So it's actually not that great a story.
我曾经知道，但现在忘了。“深喉”是20世纪70年代初的一部色情电影。那个人是马克·费尔特（Mark Felt）。他是联邦调查局副局长。他可不是白宫的朋友。有趣的是，当他的身份曝光时，曾引发了巨大的轰动。但实际上，尼克松白宫一直都知道他在向媒体泄密。所以这其实算不上什么惊天大秘密。
There's all this stuff that Woodward and Bernstein kind of rather ham up in their book about how they signaled in with flower pots on windowsills and kind of ringed i mean that's very very much the sense you get from all the presidents yeah for all the presidents men but actually the woodward and bernstein thing is not the thing that brings nixon down at all what brings him down um probably you could arguably the moment is um well here we go it's it's it's a period of of two two three days really in march 1973 so on the 21st of march the white house council that's the white house lawyer a man called john dean who's a young clean-cut kind of republican a classic kind of party political hack who's basically you know worked his way up and got his job he goes in he's been handling the cover-up for nixon and he goes in and he says this thing about there's a cancer on the presidency he says basically a lot of people have perjured themselves
伍德沃德和伯恩斯坦在书里把很多事情夸大其词，比如他们在窗台上摆花盆作为暗号之类的。我的意思是，你看《总统班底》时确实会有这种强烈的印象。但实际上，伍德沃德和伯恩斯坦的事根本不是导致尼克松下台的原因。真正导致他下台的……嗯，可以说，那个时刻是……好吧，就是1973年3月短短两三的时间。3月21日，白宫法律顾问——也就是白宫律师，一个名叫约翰·迪恩的年轻人，长相清爽、标准的共和党政客，一个标准的党派机器政客，基本上是一步步往上爬才得到这个职位——他走了进来。他一直在为尼克松处理掩盖丑闻的事，他走进去，说出了总统身上长了癌症那句话。他说，基本上许多人都在作伪证，
saying they don't know anything they don't know where it goes and we're going to run into trouble because soon the burglars are going to be sentenced sent to prison we're going to have to find more money for them and possibly money for other people if this goes up the chain and there's this dreadful conversation again on tape uh he's nixon says how much do you need and dean says um we'll need a million dollars in cash very austin powers and nixon says a million he says a million dollars i know where that can be gotten. Which is kind of very, it's very incriminating. So at that point, they have the first conversation. How far, who are we going to lose?
说他们什么都不知道，不知道事情会发展到哪里，我们要遇到麻烦了，因为很快窃贼就要被判刑入狱，我们得为他们筹集更多资金，如果事情闹大，可能还得给其他人筹集资金。然后又是一段糟糕的对话，同样被录音了。尼克松问你需要多少钱，迪恩说我们需要一百万美元现金。非常有《王牌大贱谍》的风格。尼克松说一百万？他说一百万美元，我知道从哪儿能弄到。这非常具有自证其罪的性质。所以在那个时候，他们进行了第一次对话。我们要抛弃谁？
Oh, we'll lose him and him and him. And at that moment, John Dean, this White House lawyer, can feel the kind of chill on the back of his neck because he thinks well I've been the guy who's orchestrating this cover yes yes maybe they're going to come for me and this is actually where the social mix of the Nixon White House I think is really interesting and important because I said in the previous episode lots of these people are outsiders and self-made men they have a lot to lose and no real way back if it goes wrong they're not members of boarding school old boys groups gentlemen's clubs they're not part of the
哦，我们会抛弃他、他还有他。就在那一刻，约翰·迪恩，这位白宫律师，感到了脊背发凉，因为他想，我一直是策划这场掩盖行动的人啊。是的，是的，也许他们下一个就要来抓我了。这其实正是尼克松白宫的社会阶层非常有趣且重要的地方。正如我在上一集里所说，这些人大多是局外人和白手起家的人，他们输不起，如果事情搞砸了，他们没有真正的退路。他们不是寄宿学校老男孩俱乐部的成员，也不是绅士俱乐部的成员，他们不属于华盛顿的建制派。所以如果他们倒台，他们连逃生的梯子都没有，
washington kind of establishment so if they go down there's no ladder out for them and and that's why there's no sense of kind of solidarity among them i think which there might be a question yeah there's a question from the church mouse could nixon have survived if it had been handled differently e.g the trump method of hanging others out to dry but denying nixon knew about it instead of trying to cover it this is exactly what they do tom this is exactly what their plan is so that's the 21st of march the next day dean gets sent nixon Dean to Camp David and he says I think what you should do is write a report for me about everything you know about the cover-up now at that point when the president tells you to do that you kind of think oh that that doesn't sound very good
这就是为什么我觉得他们之间没有任何团结感可言。我想这里可能会有一个问题。是的，“教堂老鼠”（Church Mouse）提问：如果处理方式不同，比如采用特朗普那种抛弃他人以求自保、同时否认自己知情的“甩锅”方法，而不是试图掩盖，尼克松能挺过来吗？汤姆，这正是他们所做的。这正是他们的计划。所以那是3月21日，第二天，尼克松把迪恩派到了戴维营，对他说，我认为你应该为我写一份报告，把你所知道关于掩盖丑闻的一切都写下来。当总统让你这么做的时候，你心里就会想：嗯，这听起来可不太妙，
because does he want me to incriminate myself does he want me to lie about what's going on here the very day after that the 23rd of march the judge is sentencing the burglars and the judge gets up in court and he says publicly in open court in front of the press he says um i've been handed a letter by one of the burglars james mccord and he reads out the letter the letter says we've been put under political pressure from the start this was never a cio operation that's not true people have perjured themselves in this um investigation and other powerful people knew about this and were behind it and you can imagine the you know report it's that hubbub in court yeah it's that classic scene of Hollywood. Rubub, rubub, rubub. Running people running.
因为他是想让我自证其罪吗？他是想让我对正在发生的事情撒谎吗？就在那之后的第二天，即3月23日，法官对窃贼进行宣判。法官在法庭上、在媒体面前公开宣读了一封信。他说：我收到了一封来自其中一名窃贼詹姆斯·麦考德（James McCord）的信。他宣读了这封信。信中说：我们从一开始就受到了政治压力，这绝不是中情局的行动，那不是真的。人们在这场调查中作伪证了，其他有权有势的人对此心知肚明并且是幕后黑手。你可以想象法庭上的那种轰动。是的，那是好莱坞式的经典场景：嗡嗡的议论声，人们在奔跑。
They're rushing off for the phone. They are rushing. But they literally are rushing for the phone. Yes. This is just absolutely unbelievable. So now things start to unravel in a really interesting way. So the 6th of April, so a little bit, just a couple of weeks later, John Dean, Nixon's White House lawyer, decides, I need a lawyer of my own to represent me.
他们冲向电话。他们真的在狂奔。不，他们确实在狂奔打电话。是的。这简直令人难以置信。所以事情开始以一种非常有趣的方式失控了。4月6日，也就是仅仅几周后，尼克松的白宫律师约翰·迪恩决定：我需要找个自己的律师来代表我。
And behind Nixon's back, he starts talking to a Senate committee that has been set up to look at campaign irregularities in 1972 called the Irvin Committee. So he starts talking to them and he starts talking to the prosecutors. So we're in April 1973. Nixon's first term has only really just started, but already things are starting to unravel. And throughout the course of this month, there was a series of meetings, Nixon and his aides, Haldeman, Ehrlichman, Dean,
在尼克松背地里，他开始与一个旨在调查1972年竞选违规行为的参议院委员会（被称为欧文委员会）进行接触。于是他开始与他们交谈，并与检察官交谈。所以时间来到了1973年4月。尼克松的第一个任期其实才刚开始，但事情已经开始失控了。在这个月的整个过程中，尼克松和他的助手们（Haldeman、Ehrlichman、Dean）举行了一系列会议，
they're kind of sitting around saying, how are we going to stop this? You know, who's going to take the fall? And with each meeting, it becomes more and more obvious that of those four men, three of them are going down, and the only question is whether they're going to take Nixon with them. So it's like the end of succession. It is.
他们坐在一起讨论：我们该怎么阻止这一切？谁来当替罪羊？每一次会议都让他们越来越清楚地意识到，在这四个人中，有三个人注定要倒台，唯一的悬念是他们会不会把尼克松也拉下水。这就像《继承之战》的大结局。确实如此。
It's very succession-like, actually. It's very succession-like, except Nixon is much more shambolic and ham-fisted than kind of Brian brian what's his name uh logan roy logan roy i love logan roy anyway um so um by the end of april nixon now knows that dean is talking to the prosecutors and all this sort of thing and he thinks the only way i can deal with this is to is to get rid of all of them. The lot, basically my my my closest aides. And there are these incredibly kind of tear stained conversations almost where Nixon says to. So if it's like a cancer, this is full operate.
真的非常像《继承之战》，只不过尼克松比布莱恩——叫什么名字来着？——洛根·罗伊（Logan Roy）要显得混乱和笨拙得多。我超爱洛根·罗伊。总之，到了4月下旬，尼克松现在知道迪恩在跟检察官谈话以及诸如此类的事情，他认为自己能处理这事的唯一办法就是除掉所有人。基本上就是把我的核心助手全炒了。这些对话甚至带有一种泪流满面的悲壮感，尼克松对他们说……如果这像癌症，这就是一场全面手术。
Yeah. Amputation. They've all got to go. I didn't know anything, but they knew everything. It was nothing to do with me. So they all go. We talked about Nixon and Quakerism in our last episode. Haldeman says this is the only time he and Nixon ever physically touched. So Quakers don't approve of excessive physical contact. And Nixon only ever shook hands with Haldeman after he'd basically fired him.
对，截肢。他们全得走人。我什么都不知道，但他们什么都知道，这跟我毫无关系。所以他们全都卷铺盖走人。我们在上一集里聊过尼克松和贵格会教派。霍尔德曼（Haldeman）说，这是他和尼克松唯一一次有过实质性的身体接触。因为贵格会教徒不赞成过度的肢体接触。尼克松只有在基本上把霍尔德曼开除后，才跟他握了握手。
He sort of said, oh, Bob, you're a great man. I'll miss you. And shakes his hand. And it's very, you know, Nixon's very Gordon Brown like, Tom. I don't think that's an unfair comparison. I think he's like a sort of more, a sort of darker, more sinister version of Gordon Brown. A trickier. Yeah, trickier.
他有点像在说：哦，鲍勃，你是个伟人，我会想念你的。然后握了握他的手。汤姆，这真的很像戈登·布朗（Gordon Brown）。我觉得这个比喻并不过分。我觉得他就像是一个更阴暗、更邪恶版本的戈登·布朗。更狡猾。对，更狡猾。
Exactly. So at that point, Nixon's presidency has kind of been amputated. He's lost his key. He's only got Kissinger left, really, of the people he ever relied on. But Kissinger is desperate to kind of keep his distance from the Watergate issue now. Has Kissinger been embroiled in this? No, although he used to pester Nixon to bug his own staff to find out who was leaking. But Kissinger wasn't involved in the campaign irregularities or anything like that at all.
完全正确。所以在那个时候，尼克松的总统职权基本上已经被“截肢”了。他失去了核心幕僚。在他曾经依赖的人里，现在真正剩下的只有基辛格了。但基辛格现在急于和水门事件保持距离。基辛格也被卷进去了吗？没有，尽管他以前经常烦扰尼克松，要求在自己的工作人员办公室里装窃听器以查出是谁在泄密。但基辛格根本没有参与竞选违规或类似的事情。
So in some ways, Kissinger, certainly in foreign policy, is now just basically running the presidency. Because Nixon is spending all his time sitting up late at night, sweating and staring into the darkness. And it's sort of very, having these kind of interior Shakespearean monologues. Yes, yes. And Dominic, in terms of foreign policy yeah 1973 is quite a turbulent year isn't it it is well we're going to come to this going on in the background there is there's lots going on in the background are you thinking about uh the unraveling of the ted heath premiership is that what you're thinking about well i think kind of energy crisis yes we're going to come to this we will get very topical we're
所以在某些方面，基辛格现在基本上独自掌管着总统府，特别是在外交政策上。因为尼克松把所有时间都花在了深夜枯坐、汗流浃背、凝视黑暗上。这感觉非常……进行着那种内心的莎士比亚式独白。是的，是的。多米尼克，就外交政策而言，是的，1973年是一个相当动荡的年份，对吧？确实如此。我们待会儿会聊到这个。幕后正在发生很多事情。你在想特德·希思（Ted Heath）首相任期的崩塌吗？你是这个意思吗？呃，我觉得有点像能源危机。是的，我们会聊到这个。我们会讲到这个非常具有时效性的话题，
going to come to this you'll see so we now get to the summer of 1973 so this scandal is now very big news and I said earlier there was a senate committee investigating it so the one of the great things about this story is that the focus keeps moving from arena to arena so it now moves to the senate committee hearings the Irvine committee hearings and they are held they are on tv they are in the at the precise the the networks clear their schedules and put them where the daytime soaps would be so it becomes a kind of soap opera in and of itself 85 percent of americans watched part of these hearings i mean that tells you just how the colossal impact of them and um so you basically and is nixon saying that this is all the cosmopolitan liberal elite? Yeah, he is.
你会看到的。所以现在我们来到了1973年夏天。这个丑闻现在成了天大的新闻。我刚才说过，有一个参议院委员会在调查此事。这个故事最棒的地方之一，就是焦点不断在各个竞技场之间切换。现在焦点转移到了参议院委员会听证会上，也就是欧文委员会听证会上。这些听证会被搬上了电视，全国各大电视网腾出黄金时段，把它们安排在原本播放日间肥皂剧的时间播出。所以它本身就变成了一种肥皂剧。85%的美国人都观看了部分听证会。这足以说明其影响力有多么巨大。那么尼克松基本上在说，这都是大都市自由派精英干的吗？对，他就是这么说的。
Out to get it. Exactly. They are bitter about the election. They've always hated him. He knew nothing about it. It's very unfortunate these things happen in the White House, but they had nothing to do with him. He would never...
他们就是冲着他来的。没错。他们对大选耿耿于怀。他们一直讨厌他。他对这一切毫不知情。白宫发生这种事实在太不幸了，但跟他一点关系都没有。他绝不会……
And we've got a question from the McRae case. Nixon's misdemeanors aside, how much of Watergate was congress getting its revenge for being sidelined over vietnam and finally finding the chance to bear its teeth there's a huge amount of truth in that actually so there's this phenomenon called the imperial presidency that people talk about um uh historians wrote about in the sort of 70s they said the presidency has become more and more powerful since the second world war and the cold war and has accumulated power and taken it from congress and particularly after vietnam this is congress's chance to reassert itself and i think there's there's loads of truth in that a lot of people in congress are itching to take back power from the presidency and they see the dirty tricks
我们有一个来自麦克雷案（McRae case）的问题：抛开尼克松的不当行为不谈，水门事件在多大程度上是国会对因越南问题而被边缘化的一次报复，并最终找到了亮出利爪的机会？这其中有很大一部分是真相。实际上存在着一种被称为“帝国总统制”的现象，历史学家在70年代左右曾对此进行过撰文探讨。他们说，自二战和冷战以来，总统权力变得越来越庞大，不断积聚权力并从国会手中夺权。特别是在越南战争之后，这是国会重新确立自身地位的机会。我认为这里面有很大一部分是真相。国会的许多人迫不及待地想要从总统手中夺回权力，他们把那些肮脏的伎俩、
the wiretaps and so on and the surveillance as a sign of a presidency that has lost any sight of kind of constitutional responsibility so i think that's a really good um question anyway the hearings there's two big moments one is where john dean the nixon's old council white house council um goes along on and this is in june and he says the president did know he knew about the cover-up and he says it's live on television he knew about it and he was in on it from the start. And actually, it's a great sensation. But lots of people think Dean is a kind of a reptilian figure.
窃听以及监控视作总统权力已经完全丧失宪法责任感的表现。所以我觉得这是一个非常好的问题。不管怎样，听证委员会有两个重大时刻。一个是约翰·迪恩——尼克松的前白宫法律顾问——在6月份出席作证。他说总统确实知道，他知道掩盖真相的事。他在电视直播中说，总统知情，并且从一开始就参与其中。这实际上引起了巨大轰动。但许多人认为迪恩是个像爬行动物一样阴险的人物。
So one columnist calls him a bottom dwelling slug. So and people sort of say not a very pleasant. Dean is very sort of slick, smarmy kind of Republican operative. And some people distrust him. They say, maybe he's lying. No, maybe Nixon didn't know. Maybe he's lying. But then the great revelation, a flunky called Alexander Butterfield goes along to be interviewed in July.
因此，有一位专栏作家称他为“底栖鼻涕虫”。人们觉得他不太讨人喜欢。迪恩是个油腔滑调、阿谀奉承的共和党政客。有些人不信任他，觉得他可能在撒谎。不，也许尼克松并不知情，也许迪恩在撒谎。但随后出现了重大爆料：一个名叫亚历山大·巴特菲尔德（Alexander Butterfield）的随从在7月份接受了质询。
And almost by sort of random chance, somebody says, there doesn't happen to be a taping system in the oval office and he's and and he had he had decided you know beforehand i won't tell them anything about tapes unless they ask and if they ask me a direct question i'm not going to purge myself and he says oh well now you come to mention it yeah there is and at that point of course you know another sort of slightly run for the phones sensation because now you can find the proof you know now you can find out one way or the other so at this point so why had nixon not destroyed the tapes well that's what most of people said why the hell did he not i mean even after the revelation some people some of nixon i think alexander haig uh who was then n's chief of staff after Oldman, says, you know, I just said to him, get a massive pile of the tapes, put them on the White House lawn, pour a load of petrol over them and just set them alight.
几乎是出于某种机缘巧合，有人问：椭圆形办公室里是不是碰巧有一套录音系统？他其实事先就已经决定了：除非他们问起，否则我什么都不会关于录音带的事；如果他们直接问我，我也绝不作伪证。于是他说：哦，既然你提到了，是的，确实有。当然，就在那一刻，又引发了一阵争相抢打电话的轰动，因为现在你们可以找到证据了，现在大家总算可以水落石出查明真相了。那么问题来了，为什么尼克松没有销毁录音带呢？这也是大多数人提出的疑问：他到底为什么不销毁？我的意思是，甚至在事情败露后，尼克松的一些手下——我想亚历山大·黑格（Alexander Haig），他后来接替霍尔德曼担任尼克松的幕僚长，曾说：我当时对他说，把一大堆录音带搬到白宫草坪上，泼上一大桶汽油，一把火烧了。
And then there's nothing they can do. But he's just paralyzed, I suppose. To destroy the tapes is an omission of guilt, right? Yeah. And he doesn't want to give because of so is there a sense in which in which nixon's i mean it sounds an odd thing to ask but is there still a kind of strain of the moral within nixon that is struggling with his his worst nature that's a good question because i mean if you're a complete criminal yeah obviously you're going to get rid of the incriminating evidence on you. I mean, the fact he doesn't.
这样他们就拿它们没办法了。但他大概只是吓呆了。销毁录音带就等于承认有罪，对吧？是的。他不想承认……那么，在尼克松身上，是不是仍然某种程度上存在着一种道德底线，正在与他内心的阴暗本性作斗争？这是一个好问题，因为如果你是个十足的罪犯，是的，你显然会除掉那些对你不利的犯罪证据。我的意思是，事实上他没有这么做。
Yes, I think that's a good point, actually. It seems a surprisingly moral thing to do. Maybe to some extent he's not. It suggests a respect for the law. Yes. Well, he keeps fighting the law. So, I mean, why doesn't he do it? Oh, I think it's just he paralyzed he's paralyzed by indecision
是的，我觉得这是一个很好的观点。这似乎是一种出人意料的具有道德感的行为。也许在某种程度上他并非如此。这表明了他对法律的某种尊重。是的。好吧，他一直在与法律对抗。所以，我的意思是，他为什么不这么做？哦，我想他只是瘫痪了，他被优柔寡断彻底瘫痪了，
he's staring at the headlights yeah um but the weird thing is this then battle this battle then goes on for for months so now it's about the tapes so now yet another sort of antagonist presents itself nixon has been forced to set up a special prosecutor. And it is, I mean, you talked about Kennedy being his worst nightmare in the last episode. The special prosecutor is, if you went into Richard Nixon's nightmares and you got somebody who would be,
他就像呆若木鸡地盯着车灯一样。奇怪的是，这场斗争随后持续了几个月。现在焦点变成了录音带。于是，又一个对头登场了。尼克松被迫任命了一位特别检察官。如果说你在上一集里谈到肯尼迪是他的最大噩梦，那么这位特别检察官，如果你钻进理查德·尼克松的噩梦里去找一个能够成为，
you know, just the ultimate bogeyman, you would find a man called Archibald Cox. Archibald Cox went to boarding school, an East Coast boarding school. He wears a bow tie. He went to Harvard, which, of course, poor old Dick Nixon didn't get to go to because his family was too poor. And he worked for the Kennedys. He was a Kennedy lawyer and he worked in the Kennedy White House.
你知道的，终极恶魔的人，你就会找到一个叫阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯（Archibald Cox）的人。阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯上过寄宿学校，东海岸的寄宿学校。他系着蝴蝶结。他上过哈佛大学——当然，可怜的老迪克·尼克松因为家里太穷而没能上哈佛。他曾为肯尼迪工作，是肯尼迪的律师，还在肯尼迪白宫工作过。
So he's the special prosecutor. And he says, I'd like to see the tapes. And Nixon says, no. And then you have this months-long battle. And eventually Nixon comes up with a... I mean, this is the deludedness, Tom. He should have burned them, you're right. What he says is, he says, I'll do a compromise with you.
所以他是特别检察官。他说：我想看看录音带。尼克松说：不行。于是双方展开了长达数月的争斗。最终尼克松提出了一个……我的意思是，汤姆，这就是他的妄想症所在。你说的对，他本该烧掉它们的。他提出的方案是：我跟你妥协，
I will release the tapes, but I'll only release them to one man who's a senator from Mississippi called John Stennis, who's incredibly senator from mississippi called john stennis who's incredibly racist and reactionary and is also deaf it says i'll release them to him and he can maybe make notes on them and tell you what's on the tapes that's not really how evidence works in court i mean it's still not quite as good as Jeremy thought but it's getting there so Archibald Cox says no that's not good
我交出录音带，但我只会把它们交给一个人——一个来自密西西比州的参议员，名叫约翰·斯泰尼斯（John Stennis）。他是个极度种族主义和反动的人，而且还是个聋子。尼克松说，我把录音带交给他，他或许可以做点笔记，然后告诉你录音带里有什么。这根本不是法庭证据应有的运作方式。我的意思是，这虽然还没达到杰里米（Jeremy）的异想天开，但也差不多了。所以阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯说：不，这远远不够，
enough you know you need to give me all these tapes Nixon says if you ask me for the tapes again because Archibald Cox is supposedly working for Nixon this is the bizarre thing Nixon says if you give me them again I'm going to sack you stop asking for my tapes and Archibald Cox asks for the tapes again.
你知道的，你需要把所有这些录音带都交给我。尼克松说：如果你再跟我要录音带——因为阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯名义上是在为尼克松工作，这真是太离奇了——尼克松说：如果你再向我要录音带，我就把你撤职，别再索要我的录音带了。结果阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯又索要录音带了。
So on the 20th of October 1973, Nixon says to his Attorney General, Elliot Richardson, fire Archibald Cox and shut down the prosecution, shut down the Special Prosecutor's Office into Watergate. Richardson says no. He resigns. Nixon gets his deputy on the phone, a man called William Ruckelshaus and he says fire archibald cox shut down the special prosecution unit and ruckelshaus says no he resigns finally they come to the third man who's a man called robert bork he's got this sort of mephistopheles kind of oh who becomes uh yeah reagan reagan nominates for the supreme court and and he doesn't get he doesn't get him. He's got this, partly because of this, because he's got this sort of Mephistopheles beard.
所以在1973年10月20日，尼克松对他的司法部长埃利奥特·理查森（Elliot Richardson）说：解雇阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯，并关闭水门事件特别检察官办公室。理查森拒绝了。他辞职了。尼克松把他的副手找来，一个名叫威廉·拉克尔斯haus（William Ruckelshaus）的人，对他说：解雇阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯，关闭特别检察官办公室。拉克尔斯豪斯也拒绝了，他辞职了。最后，他们找到了第三个人，一个叫罗伯特·博克（Robert Bork）的人。他留着那种梅菲斯特（Mephistopheles）式的胡子——哦，就是后来里根提名他进入最高法院但没能通过的那个人。部分原因就是因为这个，因为他留着那种梅菲斯特式的胡子，
He looks very sort of sinister. And he says, I'll fire him for you. So he fires Archibald Cox. The White House sends people to seal off the offices and to sort of seize the evidence that Archibald Cox has amassed, which looks kind of shocking i mean the pub that as a pr move it is an utter unalloyed catastrophe that nixon is basically sacking the person who's investigating him trying to seal off his offices take all his stuff and all this um nixon's approval rating plummets to 17 and he gets half a million telegrams the highest in western union's history of people saying you're a fascist you're trying to you know subvert the rule of law
看起来非常阴险。他说：我来帮你解雇他。于是他解雇了阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯。白宫派人封锁了办公室，并查封了阿尔奇博尔德·考克斯收集的证据。这看起来相当令人震惊。我的意思是，作为一次公关运作，这简直是一场纯粹的、毫无修饰的灾难：尼克松基本上解雇了正在调查他的人，试图查封他的办公室并没收他所有的东西。所有这些……尼克松的支持率暴跌至17%，他收到了来自西联汇款（Western Union）历史最高记录的五十万封电报，人们在电报里说：你是个法西斯，你企图颠覆法治。
and this is where your stuff about foreign policy comes in tom because this is at precisely the moment that the yom kippur war is raging between israel egypt and syria the war that is going to trigger the great opec oil shock and the energy crisis of late 1973. And at this very moment, American and Soviet ships are kind of steaming through the Mediterranean with supplies for their rival clients. So Nixon is... So America is backing Israel.
这就是你之前提到的外交政策发挥作用的地方，汤姆。因为正是在这个时候，赎罪日战争在以色列、埃及和叙利亚之间爆发了。这场战争将引发巨大的欧佩克石油危机和1973年晚期的能源危机。正是在这个关键时刻，美国和苏联的军舰正蒸汽腾腾地驶过地中海，为各自的竞争对手运送物资。所以尼克松正处于……也就是说美国在支持以色列。
Yeah, America is backing... Soviet Union is backing Alex. Exactly. And there's a sense, you know, this is escalating towards something completely out of control nixon has gone mad and is consumed by watergate on the 24th of october so four days after the so-called saturday night massacre when they tried to shut down the prosecution um the situation in the middle east is so bad that Henry Kissinger, with a couple of other kind of Nixon officials,
对，美国在支持……苏联在支持埃及。没错。人们有一种感觉，这正在升级为彻底失控的局面。尼克松已经疯了，被水门事件吞噬了。在10月24日，也就是所谓的“星期六夜间大屠杀”（即他们试图关闭检察官办公室四天后），中东局势恶化到极点，以至于亨利·基辛格伙同其他几位尼克松官员，
behind Nixon's back puts America's nuclear forces on the highest alert, DEFCON 3. So it's a really serious thing. But Nixon is not even involved in that decision because he's spending all that time sweating, sleeping late um drinking just in swearing an absolute kind yeah in an absolute mess in an absolute mess uh so anyway world war three doesn't happen um the reaction to this nixon's move is so bad that he has to appoint another prosecutor a guy called leon jaworski who has working with him a certain hillary rodham later hillary rodham clinton okay yeah um and finally nixon starts to release these tapes so the first transfer tapes comes out in november 1973 seven tapes and one of them um the one for the 20th of
在尼克松的背后，将美国的核力量提升到了最高戒备状态——三级防御状态（DEFCON 3）。所以这是一件非常严重的事情。但尼克松甚至没有参与该项决策，因为他把所有时间都花在满身大汗、熬夜睡觉、酗酒、咒骂上——简直是一团糟，简直是一团糟。总之，第三次世界大战没有爆发。外界对尼克松这一举动的反应极其恶劣，以至于他不得不任命另一位检察官，一个叫利昂·贾沃斯基（Leon Jaworski）的人。与他共事的还有一位名叫希拉里·罗德姆（Hillary Rodham，即后来的希拉里·罗德姆·克林顿）的女士。好吧，对。终于，尼克松开始公布这些录音带。第一批录音带于1973年11月问世，共七盘。其中有一盘，
june right after the watergate break-in has an 18 and a half minute strange inexplicable 18 and a half minute gap on it and everybody says what's this gap uh Nixon's chief of staff Alexander Haig says the tape must have been erased by a sinister force but I don't know what it is and then Nixon's secretary Rosemary Woods says um oh I must have accidentally erased it by pressing the wrong button when I was leaning for the phone. And then basically the prosecutors make her do this thing which proves that she could only have erased it while reaching for the phone
也就是水门事件发生后的第二天（6月20日）的那盘录音带，上面有一段长达18分半钟的、奇怪的、无法解释的18分半钟空白。每个人都在问：这段空白是怎么回事？尼克松的幕僚长亚历山大·黑格说，录音带一定是被某种神秘力量抹掉了，但他不知道那是什么。接着，尼克松的秘书罗斯玛丽·伍兹（Rosemary Woods）说：哦，一定是我在够电话时按错了键，不小心把它给抹掉了。随后，检察官们让她做了一个动作——通过在房间里做出极其高难度的杂技动作，来证明她只有在够电话时才可能把录音带抹掉。所以基本上看起来就像是尼克松自己用一种非常笨拙的方式把它抹掉了。黑格本人后来也说过，他认为尼克松听了这段录音带，本想将其彻底销毁，但因为他根本不会用机器，搞得一团糟——这就典型像那种不知该如何操作录像机的老爸一样。总之，这18分半钟的空白看起来相当糟糕，但总统毕竟还是总统，
by doing these incredible acrobatics across the room. So basically it looks like Nixon erased it himself in a very shambolic way. Haig himself has said since, he thinks Nixon listened to the tape and tried to destroy the whole tape but made a mess of it because he was terrible with equipment he didn't know you know it's the classic kind of dad who doesn't know kind of how the video recorder works um so there's this 18 and a half minute gap which looks pretty bad but still the president he's
他依然在位，丑闻还在继续发酵。换作别人，这时候大概早就逃之夭夭了，或者把自己锁在房间里，拿上一把左轮手枪和一瓶白兰地了事，但尼克松依然坚挺在那里，他打死也不肯认输，他们继续索要更多的录音带。时间来到了1974年4月。现在尼克松说：好吧，我告诉你们，我不会给你们录音带，我给你们文字记录。他心想，如果我给他们一大堆材料，那么内容实在太多了……
still president it's still lingering on so anyone else would probably run away at this point and or just you know go into a locked room with a revolver and a bottle of brandy or something but nixon is still there he can't be killed keep going they keep asking for more tapes it gets to april 1974 now nixon says well i'll tell you what, I'm not going to give you the tapes. I'll give you transcripts. So he, and he thinks if I give them loads, then they'll kind of, there'll be so much.
为什么不这么做呢？看看……对。他交出了长达1200页的对话记录，但他已经把它们全部过目了一遍。我让手下把里面所有的脏话都删掉了。
They're just, why not to do it? See the, yeah. He gives them 1200 pages worth of conversations, but he has gone through them all. I had his people go through them on, take out all the swearing.
这又是贵格会教徒的作风。所以所有的脏话都被删掉了，并用“删去脏话”（expletive deleted）代替。关于这一点，许多历史学家都写过文章，最奇怪的是，其实尼克松的粗话并没有那么糟糕。但由于他的贵格会信仰，他让人把“该死”（damn）、“见鬼”（hell）等所有这些词都删掉了。所以这就有点像“不要去想一头大象”那种感觉——哦，所有的脏话都不见了。是的，完全正确。
This is the Quaker again. So all the swearing has been taken out and replaced with expletive deleted. And the weird thing about that, I think a lot of people, historians, have written about this, is that actually Nixon's language wasn't that bad. But because of his Quakerism, he got them to take out damn, you know hell all the so so it's kind of don't think of an elephant right oh all the swear words are missing yeah exactly so everyone yeah um so he's so it's another example of the cover-up being worse it is actually this is a very good example finally the supreme court rules that he must surrender all the tapes august 1974 uh he releases a load of tapes and among them
所以每个人都……嗯。所以这又是掩盖行为比事件本身更糟糕的另一个例子。实际上，这真是一个极好的例子。最后，最高法院裁决他必须交出所有录音带。1974年8月，他公布了一大批录音带。在这些录音带中，
is the smoking gun conversation that we talked about the end of the last episode where he said to holderman get the cia to tell the fbi not to look into it and with that i mean that he has sunk because that shows that he knew about the cover-up from the very beginning, that he's lied about it ever since. There is no possible excuse. There is no way around it. The wheels of impeachment are already in motion. The House Judiciary Committee has voted to impeach him,
正是我们上一集结尾时讨论过的那盘确凿铁证的录音对话。在这盘录音中，他对霍尔德曼说：让中情局告诉联邦调局不要去调查此事。有了这个证据，就意味着他彻底完蛋了，因为这证明了他从一开始就知道掩盖真相的内幕，而且他从那以后一直在撒谎。没有任何可能的借口，也没有任何退路。弹劾的齿轮已经开始转动。众议院司法委员会已经投票决定弹劾他，
and six Republicans on the committee have voted to impeach him. It's going to go to the Senate, clearly going to go to the Senate for a trial. Then you have these incredible scenes so on the 7th of august the republican party's congressional leaders go to see nixon they basically say mr president the game is up you know you're not going to win a trial you know not even going to come close you're damaging the republican party you know you've got to go so then they they go away the republican congressional leaders and then there's this incredible scene you know very hitler in his bunker uh nixon sits alone in the darkness he listens to classical music kind of staring into the night then he calls henry kissinger and he's um he says henry i need you to come over
而且委员会中有六名共和党人也投了弹劾票。案件即将提交参议院审判，这已经是板上钉钉的事了。随后发生了戏剧性的一幕。8月7日，共和党国会领导人去见尼克松。他们基本上说：总统先生，大势已去，你知道你赢不了一场审判的，甚至连接近胜诉都不可能，你在毁掉共和党，你必须下台。接着，这些共和党国会领导人离开了。随后上演了惊心动魄的一幕——非常像希特勒在掩体里那样。尼克松独自坐在黑暗中，听着古典音乐，凝视着黑夜。然后他打电话给亨利·基辛格，说：亨利，我需要你过来一趟。
kissinger comes over and they sit together drinking brandy. Nixon starts crying. He sobs. And then he says, Henry, will you pray with me? And they get down on their knees together. And they pray. And Nixon is crying. And by some accounts, Kissinger kind of holds him like a baby there in the White House study
基辛格赶了过来，两人坐在一起喝着白兰地。尼克松开始哭泣，他嚎啕大哭。然后他说：亨利，你能陪我一起祈祷吗？两人双膝跪地，开始祈祷。尼克松痛哭流涕。据某些说法，基辛格甚至在白宫的书房里像抱婴儿一样抱着他，
and then you know what Nixon says when Kissinger finally, Kissinger thinks this is excruciating by the way, he's incredibly embarrassed, when they leave the last thing Nixon says to him Henry he says please don't ever tell anyone that I cried and that I was not
然后你知道尼克松在基辛格终于要离开时对他说什么吗？基辛格觉得这简直令人痛不欲生，尴尬极了。当他们离开时，尼克松对他说最后一句话：亨利，请你千万不要告诉任何人我哭了，我当时不够坚强。
strong and here we are talking yeah because it tells everybody okay terrible terrible behavior okay so then the eighth the next day the 8th of august he gives this resignation speech live on television then he sits up he can't sleep uh and then he actually comes to go on the 9th and and right at the beginning of the very first episode, which seems like a lifetime ago, I think it was Stefan Jensen asked, why is Watergate so resonant compared with other scandals?
而我们现在却在这里谈论此事。因为这把所有人都抖出来了……糟糕透顶的行为。好吧，到了第二天——8月8日，他在电视上发表了现场辞职演讲。接着他坐着无法入眠。直到9号，他终于要离开白宫了。在第一集的开头——感觉像是好久以前的事了，当时斯蒂芬·詹森（Stefan Jensen）问：为什么水门事件比其他丑闻更能引起共鸣？
It's because the melodrama is greater. So the 9th of August. And punctuated, I guess, by kind of certain points that people can tune in to find out what's going to happen. Exactly, exactly. So he assembles all the white house staff his family he comes out on this platform and he gives a farewell speech in which he breaks down again and again he he just he hasn't slept for days he just starts rambling
这是因为它的情节剧色彩更浓厚。所以在8月9日……我想，这也伴随着某些特定的关键时刻，人们会收听以了解接下来会发生什么。正是如此，正是如此。他召集了所有的白宫工作人员和家人，走上了这个平台，发表了告别演说。在演说中他一次又一次地情绪崩溃。他已经好几天没合眼了，开始语无伦次地东拉西扯，
he talks about his father a little man they would call him a kind of common man he talks about his mother uh who lost two sons she was a saint he says she was a saint he reads from theodore roosevelt's um memoir about when his wife died comparing himself basically somebody who's been bereaved and then he gives this i always find i know lots of people will laugh at me about this uh i always find very moving he says um his final words virtually his final words he says you know the greatness comes and you're really tested when you take some knocks some disappointment when sadness comes because only if you've been in the deepest valley can you know how magnificent it is to be on the highest mountain very sort of shakespearean wow very shakespearean and then he goes off to the helicopter the v signs and flies off
他谈到了他的父亲——一个普通人，人们会称他为平民百姓；他谈到了他的母亲，她失去了两个儿子，他说母亲是个圣人。他宣读了西奥多·罗斯福（Theodore Roosevelt）回忆录中关于他妻子去世的那段文字，基本上是将自己比作一个丧亲之人。然后他发表了一段——我总是觉得，我知道很多人会因此嘲笑我——我总是觉得非常感人的一段话。他说的几乎是临终遗言般的话：他说，当你经受打击、遭遇失望、悲伤降临时，伟大的时刻才会到来，你才真正经受了考验。因为只有当你身处最深的谷底时，你才能体会到登上最高山峰是何等的壮丽。非常具有莎士比亚风格，哇，非常具有莎士比亚风格。接着他走向直升机，挥舞着“V”字手势，乘机离去。
um to california and that's the end that's okay and i think and i think it's farewell to the first part of this second episode this is only the first part oh my god i thought you're gonna say yeah it is no no so so when we come back and and i know this is going to be agony for you but i think we've got to compress quite a lot we need to look at how uh he gets his pardon and the long-term effects of the scandal whether it had long-term effects so we will see you back after the break see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest
嗯，去加州，就这样结束了，也没关系。我想，这也是对这第二集第一部分的告别，这还只是第一部分哦天哪，我还以为你要说——对，就是这样。不，不，所以等我们回来——我知道这对你来说会是一种折磨，但我觉得我们需要压缩很多内容——我们需要看看他是如何获得特赦的，以及丑闻的长期影响，看它是否产生了长期影响。所以我们休息之后见。休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八分八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 rest
of entertainment.com that'sisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the second part of our Watergate-themed series on The Rest Is History. Nixon has resigned. He's flown off in his helicopter to California. Dominic, we have a counterfactual here um from roy nelly yeah and he asks how does u.s political history play out in a world where
of entertainment.com，即 thisisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们在《历史之巅》上推出的水门事件主题系列的第二部分。尼克松已经辞职了。他坐着直升机飞往了加州。多米尼克，我们这里有一个反事实推演，嗯，来自罗伊·内利，是的，他问：在这样一个世界里，美国的政治历史会如何发展……
ford doesn't pardon nixon okay presumably ford is easily re-elected and no ronald reagan so gerald ford is the vice president yeah under nixon therefore automatically succeeds him as president and he pardons Nixon. What happens if he doesn't? He was always going to pardon Nixon. I don't think there's a scenario in which he doesn't pardon Nixon. I like Gerald Ford, the only president of course to have appeared in a Pink Panther film
福特没有特赦尼克松？好吧，大概福特会轻松连任，也就没有罗纳德·里根了。所以杰拉尔德·福特是副总统，是的，在尼克松手下，因此自动接任总统并特赦了尼克松。如果他不特赦会怎么样？他本来就打算特赦尼克松。我觉得根本不存在他不特赦尼克松的剧本。我挺喜欢杰拉尔德·福特的，当然，他也是唯一一个出演过《粉红豹》电影的总统……
in Pink Panther Strikes Again. Big golfer, wasn't he? He was a very sport... Weirdly, everyone remembers him for falling over. But actually, he's the most athletic president in he was very he was a very sport weirdly everyone remembers him for falling over but actually he's the most athletic president in american history he's a very very good sportsman um i like joel ford a lot actually he's he used to go on holiday of course okay jim callahan um so ford pardons nixon a month after nixon leaves he has to pardon him i almost everybody around him says we cannot have nixon's trial hanging over
在《粉红豹再次出击》中。他是个高尔夫高手，对吧？他是个非常擅长运动的人……奇怪的是，所有人都记得他摔倒的样子。但实际上，他是美国历史上运动细胞最发达的总统——他是美国历史上运动细胞最发达的总统，他是个非常非常好的运动员。嗯，我其实挺喜欢杰拉尔德·福特的，他以前经常去度假，当然还有吉姆·卡拉汉……所以福特在尼克松离开一个月后特赦了尼克松，他不得不特赦他。几乎他身边的所有人都说：“我们不能让尼克松的审判一直悬在……
your presidency it will defeat everything you want to do it will completely torpedo any possibility you have of winning re-election been prejudged in the press and because there'll be no possible juror who is unaware of the scandal. So it will be very difficult. Nixon's also in atrocious health. So Nixon has phlebitis in his leg, which he's allowed to get worse and worse in the course of 1974. A lot of people think that Nixon basically had a suicide wish at this point. So he's also getting advice from people who know Nixon that say
你的总统任期头上，这会彻底毁掉你想做的每一件事，会彻底粉碎你赢得连任的任何可能。”在媒体上已经被未审先判了，因为不可能找到一个对这起丑闻一无所知的陪审员。所以这将非常困难。尼克松的健康状况也极其糟糕。尼克松的腿患有静脉炎，在1974年期间，他的病情被任由其不断恶化。很多人认为尼克松在这个时候基本上有了自杀倾向。所以他也在听取那些了解尼克松的人的建议，他们说……
Nixon may well kill himself if you um allow him to go to trial if you don't pardon him ford also is told has got legal advice that the acceptance of a pardon carries an imputation of guilt of guilt yeah um and what what is ford's relationship with nixon i mean had they got no they weren't very close so ford wasn't actually nixon's first vice president nixon's first vice president man called spiro agnew um who'd resigned because he'd been taking kind of kickbacks when he was governor of maryland spiro he hated hippies spiro agnew is a great i love spiro agnew he's like a sort of daily express columnist um yes he he goes around he talks about the nattering the daily mail ones nattering the bobs of negativism. I always like his... He attacked the...
如果你允许他接受审判，如果你不特赦他，尼克松很可能会自杀。福特还被告知，他得到了法律建议，即接受特赦带有承认有罪的暗示——有罪的暗示，是的。嗯，福特和尼克松的关系是怎样的？我是说，他们……没有，他们不是很亲密。所以福特其实并不是尼克松的第一任副总统。尼克松的第一任副总统是个叫斯皮罗·阿格纽的人，他因为在担任马里兰州州长时收受回扣而辞职了。斯皮罗，他讨厌嬉皮士。斯皮罗·阿格纽真是个……我太喜欢斯皮罗·阿格纽了，他就像某种《每日快报》的专栏作家……是的，他到处转悠，谈论那些像《每日邮报》那样的……唠叨的消极主义之鲍勃。我一直很喜欢他的……他攻击……
He talks about you, Tom. He said liberals were... What does he say? An effete core of impudent snobs who characterise themselves as intellectuals. Brilliant. That's me to a T. Yeah.
他在谈论你，汤姆。他说自由派是……他是怎么说的？“一群厚颜无耻、自诩为知识分子的傲慢自大的核心。”太精彩了。简直就是我的写照。是的。
Anyway, so Ford probably... Okay. So Ford pardons him. Yeah. Ford pardons him. Nixon doesn't die. Yeah. He... Goes to talk to david frost talks to david frost david frost gets it yeah so so so so that's watergate yeah but i think that that um we've had a lot of questions about the the impact um and why it had
不管怎样，所以福特大概……好吧。所以福特特赦了他。是的。福特特赦了他。尼克松没有死。是的。他……去跟大卫·弗罗斯特谈话，跟大卫·弗罗斯特谈话，大卫·弗罗斯特拿下了专访——所以，所以，所以，这就是水门事件。但我觉得，嗯，我们收到了很多关于其影响以及为什么它会……
this resonance so just for example um Barry Grogan, why does Watergate continue to be so famous, have such staying power? There have been much more serious presidential scandals such as Iran-Contra or Trump's actions before and on January the 6th. I mean, would you agree with that? I would actually. I think Iran-Contra certainly. Reagan was running an illegal foreign policy that had been basically explicitly banned by congress giving aid um to the contras in nicaragua uh he's what is he doing he's secretly um trading arms for hostages it's much more serious than watergate which is basically a caper i mean watergate really is a caper that a ludicrous um you know the bug okay the bugging of the democratic national committee
产生这种共鸣的问题。比如说，巴里·格罗根问：为什么水门事件能一直这么出名，拥有如此持久的影响力？明明曾经有过严重得多的总统丑闻，比如伊朗-康特拉事件或特朗普在1月6日之前及当天的行为。我的意思是，你同意这种说法吗？我其实挺同意的。我觉得伊朗-康特拉事件绝对算。里根当时在推行一项非法的对外政策，该政策基本上已被国会明确禁止，即向尼加拉瓜的康特拉反政府武装提供援助。呃，他在做什么？他是在秘密地进行人质换武器交易。这比水门事件严重得多，水门事件基本上只是一场胡闹。我是说，水门事件真的只是一场胡闹，一场荒谬的……你知道，窃听……民主党全国委员会的总部……
is not good it's it breaks the kind of democratic norms but it's not the end of the world it certainly doesn't compare with the trump support to storming the capital that's that's absolutely i mean they're not in the same league so so so obviously i guess the the impact of of watergate on america standing in the world is is not positive uh I mean yeah it's not good for America but you could couldn't you argue that actually it it shows how important the rule of law is yeah of course you could something so small can bring down you know the president of the United States you could argue Tom and you can imagine this kind of thing going on you know in other countries and nobody would bat an eyelid. Isn't Nicolas Sarkozy just been sentenced to prison in France?
这当然不对，它打破了某种民主规范，但它并非世界末日。它绝对无法与特朗普支持者冲击国会山相提并论。那是——绝对的。我是说，它们根本不在同一个量级上。所以，所以，所以很显然，我想水门事件对美国在世界上的地位的影响是不积极的。呃，我是说，是的，这对美国来说不是好事。但难道你不能说，实际上它恰恰展示了法治有多么重要吗？是的，当然可以。如此小的一件事就能扳倒美国总统。你可以这么说，汤姆。你可以想象这种事发生在其他国家，人们连眼睛都不会眨一下。尼古拉·萨科齐不刚在法国被判刑吗？
I mean, yeah, you're right. I mean, you could argue, I think it would be a reasonable argument, actually, that it reflects well on American politics. That the system works. The president has been... Is not above the law. Is not above the law. He's been party to wrongdoing. He's tried to cover it up.
我是说，是的，你说得对。我是说，你可以认为——我觉得这其实是一个合理的论点——它反映了美国政治好的一面。即系统在运转。总统没有……并不凌驾于法律之上。并不凌驾于法律之上。他参与了不当行为。他试图掩盖这一切。
And he's been caught and he has been forced from office. I mean, I think you could absolutely make that argument. I think one reason it's so resonant, going back to that first episode we did, it happens in the context of the late 1960s, Vietnam, a general loss of trust, an economic downturn, a crisis of authority generally. And it feels like part of a bigger story i mean scandals always resonate we talked about this in the thorpe episode why do scandals resonate they resonate if they express a uh they if they see they're
而他被抓了，并被迫下台。我是说，我觉得你完全可以提出这个论点。我觉得它之所以能产生如此强烈的共鸣，回到我们做的第一期节目，它的背景是20世纪60年代末、越战、普遍的信任丧失、经济低迷以及整体的权威危机。它感觉就像是一个更大故事的一部分。我是说，丑闻总能引起共鸣，我们在索普那一集里讨论过这个问题：为什么丑闻会引起共鸣？如果它们表达了一种……如果它们被视为……
seen as symptoms of a wider disease if they are kind of windows into a bigger story and watergate is exactly one of those perhaps also if they do have a slight element of the comic yes that can yeah can kind of hook people so that you have all the drama and the tension but there is also the slight element of slapstick although I don't think actually that what strikes us now the slapstick elements I think at the time a lot of Americans didn't find it funny I think they were genuinely shocked about the swearing in the Oval Office and about the kind of characters that Nixon was associated. I mean, they didn't view it as we do in a sort of cynical, flippant way. They thought this is because they really venerated the presidency. I mean, I don't think that's just Dominic. Yeah.
更广泛疾病的症状，如果它们是了解更大故事的窗口，那么水门事件正是其中之一。也许还因为它们确实带有轻微的喜剧色彩？是的，这确实能……有点吸引人们，所以你拥有了所有的戏剧性和张力，但同时也带着一丝滑稽剧的元素，尽管我不认为现在打动我们的那些滑稽元素……我觉得在当时，很多美国人并不觉得好笑。我觉得他们对椭圆形办公室里的脏话以及尼克松勾结的那类人物感到由衷的震惊。我是说，他们并没有像我们现在这样，以一种愤世嫉俗、轻浮的态度来看待它。他们认为这是因为他们真的崇拜总统职位。我是说，我不认为这只是多米尼克一个人的看法。是的。
So that leads on to another question from Duncan Simpson. We now live in a society where there is constant scandal in the news and the proven lies from our leaders are met with very little uproar. How much did Watergate change the idea of faith in our leaders and an expectation of them being good people? Yeah, I think it definitely damaged Americans' faith in the presidency. I mean, that's one reason they turned to Reagan, actually, in 1980. I think there's a thirst for somebody who, you know, will restore, as people see it, the grandeur, the kind of regal magnificence of the presidency. And is that why Reagan is able to weather the Iran-Contra scandal?
这就引出了邓肯·辛普森的另一个问题。我们现在生活在一个新闻中丑闻不断、领导人被证实的谎言也只会引发极小骚动的社会中。水门事件在多大程度上改变了人们对领导人的信念以及对他们成为好人的期待？是的，我觉得它绝对损害了美国人对总统职位的信念。我是说，这也是他们在1980年转向里根的原因之一。我觉得人们渴望有一个能够——正如人们所看到的——恢复总统职位的宏伟气势和那种帝王般壮丽的人。这难道就是里根能够经受住伊朗-康特拉事件考验的原因吗？
Yeah, I think absolutely. People just didn't want it. There's no appetite for it. They just didn't want it. But then it does, you see, then you do have the Clinton impeachment in the 1990s. And that is seen as kind of, I mean, certainly Democrats see that as Republicans deliberately trying to get revenge for Walter Gellert. They absolutely do, because people point to the fact that Hillary Clinton had been working for the special prosecution team in 1974. Although, of course, I always think with the clinton impeachment you know everybody's for 20 for you know 10 15 years people said ah it's nothing it's a storm in a teacup you know it's
是的，我完全这么认为。人们只是不希望这样。没有这种胃口。他们就是不希望这样。但随后，你看，到了20世纪90年代，你又迎来了克林顿弹劾案。而这被视为一种——我是说，民主党人绝对认为那是共和党人蓄意为水门事件进行报复。他们绝对是这么认为的，因为人们指出希拉里·克林顿曾在1974年为特别检察官团队工作过。不过，当然，我总是觉得对于克林顿弹劾案，你知道，每个人都——持续了20年，持续了（你知道的）10年、15年，人们都说：“噢，这算什么，大惊小怪，你知道的，这……
just a republican concocted um and now i think people post kind of me too don't you think people look at that clinton and lewinsky and think that was actually pretty shabby i don't know i i mean i think it's hard to take the the republicans of that period seriously you're right kind of woke gender warriors yeah yes that's very true especially as most of them ended up you know being brought down by the by the business as well um exactly yes i mean i think but i mean but one thing that's i do think is is a you could argue a dangerous legacy of watergate is the tendency to kind of criminalize presidential politics so you know america has had a lot of impeachments now compared with the previous hundred years or so
只是共和党人捏造的……”而现在，我觉得在“我也是”运动（Me Too）之后，你不觉得人们回看当年的克林顿和莱文斯基事件，会觉得那其实相当卑劣吗？我不知道。我是说，我觉得很难认真对待那个时期的共和党人，他们就像那种“觉醒”的性别战士。是的，这话非常对，尤其是因为他们中的大多数人最终也被……也被这件事给扳倒了……完全是的。是的，我是说，但我觉得有一件事——你可以认为这是水门事件的一个危险遗产——那就是将总统政治刑事化的倾向。所以，你知道，与过去的一百年左右相比，现在的美国已经经历了很多次弹劾。
um well dominic do you remember that the the very first episode we recorded that in the end didn't go out because we weren't very good yeah where we just lectured each other nothing's changed well we we but we did a comparison between ancient rome and modern america we recorded it and we did one of the things that happens in ancient rome is is that um the law becomes a weapon yeah in kind of political rivalries and the chance to prosecute and drag down a rival kind of contributes to the turbulence of the late Roman Republic. And would you see the same thing happening?
嗯，多米尼克，你还记得我们录制的、最终没有播出的第一集吗？因为当时我们表现得不太好。是的，我们在节目里互相长篇大论。一切都没有变。好吧，我们——我们确实对古罗马和现代美国进行了对比。我们录了那一集。在古罗马发生的事情之一就是，法律变成了政治竞争中的一种武器，而起诉和拖垮竞争对手的机会，助长了罗马共和国晚期的动荡。你认为同样的事情也在发生吗？
Undoubtedly. Undoubtedly, actually. And it's interesting because once you get to the Trump impeachment, that, unlike the Nixon impeachment that unlike the nixon impeachment which obviously didn't reach its culmination the trump impeachment certainly the first one was absolutely perceived in terms of party politics wasn't it i mean nobody it divided on partisan lines except for mitt romney i think and nobody there was no sort of sense of the rule of law being a standard above petty partisan politics which i think there was no sort of sense of the rule of law being a standard above petty partisan politics which i think there was in 1974 it i mean it was basically you know we've got to stand up to russia
毫无疑问。毫无疑问，确实如此。很有意思的是，一旦到了特朗普弹劾案，这一点——与尼克松弹劾案不同，尼克松弹劾案显然没有走到高潮——特朗普弹劾案，至少第一次弹劾，绝对是被当作党派政治来对待的，不是吗？我是说，没有人……它完全是按党派划线分裂的，除了米特·罗姆尼（我想），根本没有人……那种法治是一种超越狭隘党派政治的标准的意识不复存在了——我觉得在1974年，那种意识是存在的。我是说，那基本上就是，“我们必须挺身对抗俄罗斯……”
or we've got to stand up to china yeah and so that was it was also a kind of policy divide wasn't it well i suppose um but it was also just purely seen as a referendum on what do you support trump or do you not support him okay so stephanie edson of the show, but is being a little bit greedy here. I'm not going to deny because this is his second question. Yeah, in two episodes, though. I mean, yes. Yeah, well, all right. But it's a good question. So we'll forgive him. Would Trump have been impeached if he did the exact same thing today? To what extent have cross-partisan norms and trust been eroded to the point that there is always no limit to what a party will accept from their president that is or i suppose conversely
或者“我们必须挺身对抗中国”。是的，所以这就是……这也算是一种政策分歧，对吧？嗯，我猜……但它也被纯粹视为是一场全民公投：你究竟支持特朗普，还是不支持他？好吧，那么节目的常客斯蒂芬·埃德森在这里有点贪心了。我不会否认这一点，因为这是他的第二个问题。是的，不过是在两集里。我是说，是的。是的，好吧。不过这是一个好问题，所以我们原谅他。如果特朗普今天做了完全相同的事情，他会被弹劾吗？跨党派的规范和信任在多大程度上已经被侵蚀到这样一种地步：政党对他们的总统所能接受的行为永远没有底线……或者反过来说……
to what what an opposition will do to bring down a president that's a really that's a really excellent and actually slightly um disturbing question because i think stefan's implication is probably right that uh trump certainly would have said everybody does it you know fake news the media how many republicans would have fallen into line behind him well i think you just look at the react you know he he got a what he he was not him he was not convicted in the second impeachment after the storming of the capital i mean if you won't you won't convict him for that you'll never convict him yeah so i mean that's your answer i think isn't it that that's i think um any president i'm sure it probably works the other way around as well by the way i and when you once you have a hyper partisan political environment then it becomes impossible to
反对派为了扳倒总统会无所不用其极？这是一个非常、非常棒，而且实际上略微有些……令人不安的问题。因为我觉得斯蒂芬的潜台词可能是对的，即特朗普肯定会说：“所有人都在这样做，假新闻，媒体。”有多少共和党人会乖乖排队支持他？好吧，你看一下反应就知道了——他在冲击国会山之后的第二次弹劾中没有被定罪。我是说，如果你连这个都不给他定罪，那你永远也不会给他定罪。所以，我是说，这就是你的答案，不是吗？我觉得这就是……任何总统——我确信这种逻辑反过来也同样适用，顺便说一句。一旦你陷入了超党派的政治环境，那么想要……
appeal to some sort of sense of the rule of law that transcends politics. Loser's consent has basically gone in America, hasn't it? I mean, would that be too much of an exaggeration? No, I think... Not entirely, obviously. And I think Clinton is where you saw that. There were lots of Republicans who viewed Clinton as an illegitimate president. Even though he'd won the 1992 election fair and square. He was re-elected in 1996.
呼唤那种超越政治的法治精神就变得不可能了。“失败者的默许”在美国基本上已经不复存在了，不是吗？我是说，这会不会太夸张了？不，我认为……当然也不是完全不存在。我觉得你在克林顿身上就能看到这一点。当时有很多共和党人将克林顿视为一个非法的总统，尽管他在1992年的大选中堂堂正正地赢了，而且在1996年成功连任。
But there were lots of people who just thought we have to get him fair means or foul yeah um and okay so this is yeah yeah so there's there's an absolute train of a within american politics that you can see but there's also and this is again a great question from bartman 1981 to what extent have the many films on nixon and Watergate influenced and perhaps misinformed the public perception on the subject? And I would like to expand that to say, to what extent has the idea of paranoia, of conspiracy, of covers up, that has become a massive part of popular American culture, to what extent do you think that has corroded the norms of American democracy?
但依然有很多人觉得，无论用什么正当或不正当的手段，我们都必须把他弄下台。是的，嗯……好吧，所以……这里面绝对存在一条美国政治的脉络，你可以看得清清楚楚。但同时——这又是巴特曼1981提出的一个好问题——关于尼克松和水门事件的众多电影，在多大程度上影响并可能误导了公众对这一主题的看法？我想将其引申一下，即：关于阴谋、掩盖真相的偏执观念，已经成为美国流行文化中极其庞大的一部分，你认为这种观念在多大程度上腐蚀了美国民主的规范？
Yeah, I think that's a really good point, Tom. I think it has corroded it, undoubtedly. The idea of the corrupt establishment, sinister forces, all that stuff. I mean, actually, that's already there before Watergate happens. It's kind of in the air. There's a whole load of films from the early 70s.
是的，我觉得这是一个非常好的观点，汤姆。它确实腐蚀了民主，毫无疑问。腐败的建制派、阴暗的力量，所有这些东西。我是说，实际上，在水门事件发生之前，这些就已经存在了。它们就弥漫在空气中。70年代初有一大批这样的电影。
There's obviously All the President's Men. There's a film called The Conversation. I think that's 1972. That's about taping. Gene Hackman. There's a film called, a brilliant film called The Parallax View about assassinations. Again, 1974. And there is this sort of sense
显然有《总统班底》。有一部电影叫《窃听大阴谋》，我想那是1972年的。讲的就是窃听。吉恩·哈克曼主演的。还有一部电影，一部关于暗杀的绝妙电影叫《视差》——也是1974年的。所以确实存在这样一种感觉：
of American cinema in the early 70s being very paranoid and all about conspiracies and stuff yes of course I think it probably is damaging it reflects a general loss of faith in authority that had a lot to do with Vietnam but obviously as we now know because we have it in Britain
70年代初的美国电影非常偏执，全都是关于阴谋诡计之类的东西。是的，当然，我觉得这可能是有害的。它反映了对权威的普遍信任危机，这与越战有很大关系。但显然，正如我们现在所知道的那样——因为我们在英国也能看到——西方世界的每个地方都有这种现象。它超越了这一点，你不觉得这很有害吗？我是说，你和我可以用一种轻浮的方式开玩笑说：“哦，我们喜欢阴谋论电影。”但它们确实很重要。我是说，它们确实会影响人们思考政治的方式。好吧，我当时在想，克林顿弹劾案的背景其实是《X档案》。是的。
everywhere in the western world has it goes beyond that don't you think it's damaging? I mean you and I can joke about it in a sort of flippant way and say, oh, we love conspiracy theory films. But they do matter. I mean, they do affect the way people think about politics. Well, I was kind of thinking that the backdrop to the Clinton impeachment was X-Files. Yeah.
表面上它是关于外星人的，但实际上是关于各种掩盖真相、你不能信任政府、以及……没有什么是真的。而这确实在某种程度上提供了……它的受欢迎程度显然迎合了那种“你在政府里谁也不能相信”的心态。是的，而且在某种程度上，这种心态在美国一直存在，因为美国显然是建立在对政府的不信任之上的——也就是对乔治三世和反政府精神的不信任。我是说，正如历史学家理查德·霍夫施塔特（Richard Hofstadter）著名的论断，将其称为美国政治中的“偏执风格”：那种你一直拥有的感觉，最初是天主教徒要来搞他们，后来则是共产主义者。但这难道不能回答那个问题吗：为什么水门事件会产生如此巨大的影响？是因为它其实正符合了……
Which ostensibly was about aliens, but actually was about kind of cover-ups and that you can't trust the government and that um nothing is true um and that actually that did kind of provide you know its popularity was obviously buying into a sense that you can't trust anybody yeah in government yeah and that's always been there in america to some extent because america is obviously founded on a distrust of government i.e of george iii and the anti-government spirit um i mean what the historian richard hofstadter famously called the paranoid style in american politics the sense that you had in there that's always been there initially it was catholics out to get them and and then it was communist but is that does that answer the question then of why Watergate has has had this kind of massive impact is that actually it kind of goes with the grain of what
美国相当一部分人对政府行径的某种怀疑？是的，我想是的。我想关于美国人对此反应的一个有趣之处在于：如果这件事发生在法国，你知道，大家肯定会耸耸肩，然后说：“哦，好吧，政客们不就是这样嘛，”诸如此类。是的，嗯……我是说，法国政治极其腐败，对吧？我是说萨科齐、希拉克、密特朗，你知道的，名单长得数不过来。但同时也有那种……理查德·尼克松这个贵格会信徒会认同的那种感觉：我们是一个生活清白、头脑清醒、崇尚新教、敬畏神的民族，我们应该成为……我们是一座光芒耀眼的山巅之城。我是说，很多人……
quite a lot of people in the United States kind of suspected about the doings of government yes I suppose so and I suppose one thing that's interesting about the American reaction to is had it happened in France you know there'd have be an awful lot of shrugging and people sort of saying yeah oh well that's what politicians do you know kind of yeah um uh i mean french politics is incredibly corrupt right i mean sarkozy shirak mitterrand you know list as long as your arm um but there is also that kind of you know what the quaker and richard nixon would have recognized that that kind of sense of we're a clean living sober protestant godly people and we should be we're a shining city on a hill which i mean lots of people
在水门事件期间都这么说过：我们应该成为世界的榜样，我们是美国，我们不干这种事，这不是美国该有的样子。是的。正如每个人在国会山骚乱之后所说的那样，不是吗？“这不是美国。”好吧，其实它就是。现在它差不多就是这个样子了。
said this during watergate we should be the example to the world we're america we don't do this you know this isn't America. Yeah. Yes. As everybody said, as everybody said after the Capitol insurrection, didn't they? This is not America. Like, well, it kind of is. Kind of is now.
是的。好了，节目即将接近尾声，但让我们把话题转回尼克松本人身上。是的。所以这是一个贯穿两集、一直萦绕不去的问题：如果你认为水门事件没有把他拉下马，大家会如何评价他？他会被记住是一位令人印象深刻的总统吗？我觉得他会的。你是否认为……水门事件玷污了他本来可以取得的那些成就的名誉，因为他被看作是一个邪恶的人？我是说，小偷理查德……
Yes. Okay. Well, coming to the close, but let's just turn it back to Nixon himself. Yeah. So this is a kind of question that's been shadowing the entire both both episodes really which is how do you think he would be judged had Watergate not tripped him up would he be remembered as as as an impressive president I think he would actually and do you think that um that Watergate has has kind of tarnished the memory of the achievements that he he could clock up um because he's seen as a kind of evil person. I mean, Tricky Dicky,
就像我们在第一集开头提到的亨特·汤普森说的那样，他就像一块浮在下水道里的道德粪便。没错。这话太严厉了。非常、非常强烈。我觉得这非常……是的。我觉得人们，但尼克松身上也有一种喜剧色彩，不是吗？
the Huntress Thompson that we began episode one with, he is a kind of moral turd floating in the sewer. Right. That's very harsh. Very, very strong. I think that's very, yes. I think people, but there's also a comic sense to Nixon, isn't there?
我是说，人们把尼克松印在T恤上，或者……尼克松那垂肉的脸庞本身的形象，打保龄球什么的，被视为一种有趣而又带点复古的东西。我觉得他在《辛普森一家》里挺搞笑的。是的，完全正确。他上过节目。他经常出现在一个叫《飞出个未来》的类似《辛普森一家》的节目里。
I mean, people have Nixon on T-shirts or they have kind of, the very image of Nixon with his kind of jowly face. Bowling or something is seen as as amusing and kind of retro. I wish it's funny on The Simpsons. Yeah, exactly. He was on. He was often on a show called Futurama kind of Simpsons type show.
是的，我觉得尼克松是一位迷人且富有创造力的总统，他在动荡的时期执政，而且实际上往往比人们所给予他的评价要开明得多。在外交政策方面，你知道，他取得了巨大的成就，比如缓和局势等等，去访问莫斯科。所以把他和特朗普作比较——哦，太荒谬了。关于尼克松的另一件事是——我刚才说过，我们在第一集里谈到过，我在谢菲尔德大学当学者时曾教过这门课。这门课持续一整学年，我们每周开会四个小时，详细梳理了尼克松的整个职业生涯以及水门事件。我们研究得极其细致。所以这可以说是典型的马克思主义学者的作风。没错。
Yeah, I think Nixon was a fascinating and creative president governing in troubled times who was actually much more liberal often than he's given credit for and in terms of foreign policy you know had tremendous achievements detente and so on going to moscow so the comparison of him to trump oh it's ridiculous the other thing about nixon so i said that we talked in the first episode how i taught this course when I was an academic at Sheffield. It ran all year and we met for four hours a week and we went through Nixon's whole career in Watergate. We did it in enormous detail. So this is kind of typical Marxist academics. Right.
颠覆体面的、右翼思考问题的理解方式。我必须说，学生们上完这门课后，对尼克松产生了难以置信的同情。这可不只是我的洗脑。其中一个后来成为了……他自己也成了一名历史学家，我想他现在在诺丁汉大学任教，他曾对我说……我记得他在研讨会上说过：
Undermining decent right thinking ways of understanding. And I have to say the students ended it incredibly sympathetic to Nixon. And it wasn't just my brainwashing. It's one of them who actually went on to become a... He is a tragic hero. Yeah, one of them who went on to become a historian himself, and I think he's at Nottingham, said to me... I can remember him saying in the seminar, he said,
“关于尼克松，作为一个男人，当你审视尼克松时，你会看到你自己的身影。他所有的焦虑都是那种男子气概的焦虑：你会觉得别人比你过得更有趣，女孩们不看你，你腋下直冒冷汗，完全没错，你得把孩子们的照片……你穿错了鞋子，你知道的，你根本不知道该怎么举止。你分不清勃艮第酒和波尔多酒。你为了来到这里付出了那么多努力。
the thing about Nixon is, as a man, when you look at Nixon, you kind of look you see yourself all his anxieties are the anxieties of kind of masculinity that you're kind of you know there are people having more fun than you that the girls aren't looking at you that the part of sweat gathering under you exactly you you have you've got to put your children's on you've got the wrong shoes you know you you don't really know how to behave. You don't know what difference between Burgundy and Bordeaux. You've worked so hard to get here.
你知道的，你比任何人都努力。然而他们总是会看不起你，对你冷嘲热讽。”试图掩盖那张违章停车罚单。螺旋式失控。但是的，完全正确。内心深处明知、那种挥之不去的恐惧——你做过的那件可怕的事，当时看起来……内心深处明知、那种挥之不去的恐惧——你做过的那件可怕的事，当时看起来那么微不足道，最终却会把你拉下马。我觉得这里面有一种……
You know, you've worked harder than anybody else. And yet they will always look down on you and sneer at you. Trying to cover up that parking ticket. Spiral that control. But yeah, exactly. The knowledge at the back of your mind, the nagging fear, that terrible thing you did, which seemed the knowledge at the back of your mind the nagging fear that terrible thing you did which seems so small at the time is going to bring you down i think there's something
如此……如此引人共鸣的情感注入在尼克松身上。如果你在尼克松身上看不到自己的影子，那你才有问题呢。好吧，我觉得这是一个极其精彩的收尾。你像尼克松吗？如果你不像，那你才有问题呢。现代美国顶尖、顶尖、顶尖、顶尖的历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克已经发话了。伴随着这个结论，我们要和大家道别了。再见。再见。
so so sort of empathetic in in nixon and if you can't see yourself in nixon there's something wrong with you that's okay well i think that's an amazing note on which to end. Are you like Nixon? If you're not, there's something wrong with you. Top, top, top, top historian of the modern United States, Dominic Sandbrook, has spoken. And on that note, we will bid you farewell. Farewell. Goodbye.
再见。感谢收听《历史之巅》。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁节目、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听独家节目、提前解锁、免广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。